let's summarize this what I'm gonna ask
you to do in your book and it doesn't
have to be super neat but I'm gonna ask
you to draw a table for me and the
tables gonna look something like this
three columns roughly I want us to bring
all the links between differentiation
and integration and all of the big
amount of notation that you've amassed
over the last or sort of six to seven
months and I want to make sure you can
see it all together in one place this is
kind of going to be a summary for us if
at any point I'm riding too fast for you
don't remember don't forget we're going
to give you the recording for this and
I'll even give you the exact PDF of what
I've written here but let's have a go
and see how much of this we can fill in
together all right we'll start on left
hand side when you differentiate the
result that you get which we often call
f dash or dy and DX we call that the
derivative right that's the result that
you get out of this process of
differentiation now conversely to that
when you integrate we have a few
different names for the result that you
get the opposite of a derivative is the
primitive like primitive humans that's
where we came from right but in certain
contexts rather than calling a primitive
we'll call it an integral you integrate
you get an integral no big surprises
there now what's the notation we've been
using for these derivatives well like I
said you might see dy/dx you might see F
dash X and what that is is a shorthand
for that first principal stuff that we
learned early in year 11 and for you
guys who want a bit of a refresher on
that it's one with that limit and we've
got this f of X plus h minus f of X
that's the rise that you can see divided
by H which is the run so this is really
just a fancy way of saying tell me the
gradient and tell me what it looks like
as it changes over time for very very
small intervals
okay now the integration notation is the
one that we just introduced here when
you differentiate you get f dash when
you integrate often what we say is you
get capital air for some people even
call it f Prime but it's a bit tricky
because different people around the
world I could be going Google or have a
look at other textbooks and sometimes
you use different they mean different
things when they say F prime so I'm just
gonna use the capital F generally pretty
agreed-upon
what we get when we do this process of
integration summing up all these areas
now I want you to think back to the
first time you met this notation this is
what we call the indefinite integral and
for those you playing along at home it's
where you get that constant of
integration right where you're like I'm
not sure which integral this is it's one
of them I might need more information to
find out which one okay now what happens
when you take the result of that a
derivative or an integral and you start
to put numbers into it you start to
evaluate things put particular values
well if you get like a number like let's
just say for example a number like x
equals 2 and if you put that in f - 2
using our function notation you put an x
value in you're going to get an another
value out of that will interpret that in
the next row when you have a look at an
integral it becomes a little more
complicated because you don't just put
in one number in it - into an integral
as we saw in our examples up above you
actually put two numbers there's a start
and then there's an endpoints so again
just as an example we might say I'm
going to integrate from say 2 to 5 these
are my lower and my upper bounds I'm
going to integrate this function I will
get the the primitive out of that and
I'm going to say well I I do the value
at the top take away the value from the
bottom now the way that we write this is
to say you get your primitive function
in here we write these square brackets
and outside the square brackets we write
those upper and lower balance that we
had from the original question and
that's just shorthand for what we just
said you take away the end eval you and
you subtract sorry you take you put in
the end value and you take away the
beginning value and rather than being an
indefinite integral this is what we call
a definite integral it has a specific
value it doesn't have any X's or other
pronumerals in it it's just going to be
a number just like what happens if you
put x equals 2 into f - now here are the
most important parts okay all of that
stuff that notation doesn't mean
anything if you can't interpret it
and know what it actually stands for
what's the point well we've been doing
derivatives for a while now we know if
you take F dash 2 what does that tell
you about a graph what it tells you is
the gradient of that graph at that
particular chosen x-value the gradient
at x equals 2 what does the internal
tell you well I come back to this guy
here it tells you like we saw last
lesson an area under a curve in a
specific place an area under a curve in
a specific place so in the example that
I just wrote up here in the table I
would say it's the area from x equals 2
all the way to x equals 5 and where I
got those numbers from let's pick a
another color here is this value here is
where I started and this other value
over here is where I end you can see
them corresponding in the upper and
lower limits over there
ok now the final question is what's it
all mean like when I come back to Mike
over 19 graph like what do i what do I
get to say about it and about out the
situation we find ourselves in on the
basis of this differentiation and this
integration well it's about firstly
what's the rate of change like how
quickly are things you know changing for
us
are we getting lots and lots of new
cases each day or is it thankfully
starting to slow down what's the rate of
change and when we look at area again
this is the actual very first question
we're coming full circle now I'm going
to end where I began the meaning of this
is the question we began with what's the
total amount like what's changed over
this period of time probably the most
technically accurate way to say it is
what's the net amount of change and I
use that word net very specifically
because we're going to eventually work
out that unlike our conventional idea of
area like areas of measurement has to be
positive if we have a look at the graph
that we started with suppose we go into
the future I'm really hoping that at
some point you know people start
recovering from this in fact we already
know people have started to recover and
we might say well the number of
diagnoses across the population is no
longer increasing it's actually getting
to a point where it's
decreasing and that means the net amount
of change over time would be negative
we're starting to recover from this
situation right so that's why I use that
word net amount of change because it can
indicate well this number unlike a
normal kind of area that we used to over
the last few years this might be
negative and not positive